hello hi this is John Baron publicist
for Donald Trump oh hey John how are you
it's Donald Trump
listen you haven't paid me in over six
years you owe me a lot of money you jerk
okay now just slow down there John
listen I missed a few payments hey you
know I don't know if you know it but I
become president I can get you the money
oh how many times have I heard that you
jerk
you never pay anybody not only that you
use your kids as a human shield to
defend against your crappy personality
and low moral standing hey you better
step back or else I'll send a Delta
Force to take you out you understand me
John Barrett you're a dead man don't you
threaten me you understand what I can do
I can expose all your secrets oh whoa
whoa whoa no let's slow down slow down
let's slow down let me just get another
guy in on the call here okay hold on
just for a second hello Dennis Dennison
yeah hey it's me president Trump listen
I need you to talk to John Berry and I
put you into the call hello Dennis
Dennison hi this is John Barrett who's
this
Dennis Dennison on the guys who slept
with stormy Daniels I'm a big pervert oh
don't give me this crap put the
president back on the line I can't deal
with any more aliases alias that was a
hit show that nobody really cared about
but the truth was it was wonderful who's
talking right now is this Dennis or the
president no this is Dennis now the
president's still here it's John Baron
it's all right it's all right it's all
right thanks a lot goodbye
you